[Música]
hola juana entre es un gusto de
saludarte hola pablo cómo estás
muy bien juegan presto estás trabajando
en la actualidad
un documental con sobrevivientes en el
salvador las masacres de chalatenango
cómo surgió la idea de hacer este
documental
chalatenango es una un departamento en
el norte del salvador cerca de la
frontera con honduras y a principios de
los años 80 al principio de la guerra
civil fue el escenario de cruentas
masacres de posibles abusos en materia
de humanos los sobrevivientes de esas
masacres están muy interesados en
preservar su lista de agentes para lo
que allí ocurrió de modo que eso no
ocurra de nuevo ni el salvador ni el
entonces viaje por primera vez el
salvador en el año 2017
junto a un grupo de investigadores que
están apoyando los esfuerzos de estas
comunidades para salvar su memoria
histórica' ellos estaban buscando apoyo
para el registro audiovisual de sus
historias y desde ese momento comencé a
trabajar con ellos
es un trabajo de colaboración donde
estoy contribuyendo en la preservación
en el registro de lo que ellos vieron y
de lo que ellos vivieron de la memoria
histórica
y entonces cuando cuando sucedieron como
tal las masacres con andrés
la masacre del zoom pool que es la más
grande de las masacres que allí ocurrió
tuvo lugar el 14 de mayo en 1980 en ese
primer viaje que dice el salvador tuve
la oportunidad junto con sobrevivientes
de ir al lugar donde donde donde ocurrió
la masacre es un sitio que se llama las
aradas que es a la orilla del río sumpul
que separa el salvador de honduras allí
tuvo lugar la masacre el 14 de mayo de
1980 esté allí estaba
acampando un grupo de civiles en su
mayoría mujeres niños y ancianos que
estaban huyendo que estaban escapando y
allí fueron
en víctimas de un operativo combinado
del ejército la guardia nacional y una
organización paramilitar llamada orden
y cuál es el contexto en ese momento en
ese lugar cuando entres en la guerra ya
ya estaba en pleno desarrollo un
conflicto que duró desde 1970 hasta 1992
una guerra larga y cruenta estas
masacres en su mayoría ocurrieron a
principios de la década de los 80
estas personas que allí fueron
asesinadas eran campesinos
algunos de ellos habían comenzado a
organizarse durante los años 70 luchando
por reivindicaciones exigiendo mejores
condiciones de trabajo y de vida y por
esa razón fueron perseguidos es un
conflicto complejo donde hay unas élites
que se aferraban al poder hay un
movimiento guerrillero que quería tomar
el poder y hay intereses internacionales
que intervinieron en el conflicto
se dice que la guerra en centroamérica
es el último episodio de la guerra fría
estos estas personas estas que murieron
en estas masacres en definitiva fueron
víctimas del enfrentamiento entre estas
fuerzas y como suele pasar son los
civiles los que llevan la peor parte
entonces qué pasó se encontraron ellos
entre dos fuegos o sea quienes le
dispararon los el ejército o los
rebeldes
en ese momento él
el ejército
desarrollaba una serie de operativos en
esta zona
las personas a consecuencia de estos
operativos tenían que dejar sus casas
tenían que dejar sus pueblos sus
comunidades y esconderse para para no
morir hay una había una política de
tierra arrasada donde no solamente se
perseguía a estos campesinos sino que
también se destruían sus cultivos de tal
manera que eso subsistencia fuera
amenazada estas personas huían se
escondían en los campos se escondían en
las montañas y este grupo en concreto
que estaba en las gradas estaba a
orillas del río sumpul porque había la
idea de que cruzando el zoom pull hacia
el otro lado donde están duras podían
salvar sus vidas lo que no sabían ellos
es que había ya complicidad entre las
fuerzas armadas salvadoreñas y el
ejército de honduras entonces cuando
ocurre el operativo en las aradas y la
gente trata de escapar hacia el otro
lado se encuentran con los soldados
hondureños disparando los del otro lado
las historias son terribles porque es
mayo es la época de lluvias en el
salvador y la noche anterior había
llovido torrencialmente entonces el río
estaba crecido y cuando la gente trataba
de escapar muchos fueron arrastrados por
la corriente estamos hablando de madres
o padres cargando a sus hijos y viviendo
como sus hijos que caían al agua y se
los llevaba la corriente estamos
hablando de gente que que no pudo llegar
al otro lado y hay gente que cuando
llegó ejemplo los recibieron con
disparos es un un episodio muy muy
triste de la historia de no sólo el
salvador sino de américa latina en
general entre otras cosas porque en su
momento esto no se supo y siguieron
pasando cosas parecidas el objetivo de
estos operativos aparte de de sembrar el
terror entre estas personas era también
que esto sirviera como un mecanismo para
sembrar temor y que la gente no nos
apoyara los movimientos que estaban en
ese momento luchando por
reivindicaciones y por transformaciones
políticas y sociales
juan andrés entonces en este contexto lo
que yo entiendo es que el ejército
salvadoreño daba por contado de que el
pueblo estaba trabajando con la
guerrilla igualmente de parte de los
hondureños
es un tema complejo porque es importante
esto está en el informe de la comisión
de la verdad investigó estos hechos al
final de la guerra
y este informe está publicado está
disponible online para quien lo quiera
revisar se llama de la locura a la
esperanza y es el informe de la comisión
de la verdad con participación de las
naciones unidas y organismos
internacionales y se responsabiliza al
estado por alrededor de un 85% del total
de abusos que se cometieron en esos años
y en buena medida estos abusos fueron en
contra de población civil población
civil que es cierto que algunos de ellos
estaban organizados para trabajar en pro
de sus comunidades pero no
necesariamente organizarse formando un
sindicato de campesinos por ejemplo
quiere decir que estas personas estaban
luchando
con armas eso es importante que es que
se sepa y que se diga porque las
personas que estaban en las aradas eran
eso pues eran las mujeres eran niños
eran ancianos no eran combatientes no
eran no eran guerrilleros es gente
simplemente que que le tocó es
estar allí en un momento histórico muy
muy complejo algunos de ellos
más tarde si se incorporaron a la lucha
armada pero lo hicieron un poco en
consecuencia de esos mismos atropellos
de los que fueron víctimas por parte del
estado
este
pero no miramos las personas que estaban
allí no no eran no era era un ejército
guerrillero no eran no eran combatientes
eran civiles desarmados
y este fue juan andrés ese fue el
comienzo de la migración salvadoreña
hacia canadá en ese momento es un es un
evento que tuvo una incidencia
importante porque a raíz de la masacre
del sub pool y de otras masacres que
ocurrieron en esos años
mucha gente se refugió en honduras
pasado esto
este operativos y muchas personas
lograron cruzadas
así como el como el ejército de honduras
apoyó este operativo participó de este
operativo hay muchísimas comunidades en
honduras que recibieron a los aguados de
leer salvadoreños y les dieron
protección y luego se establecieron en
honduras una serie de campos de
refugiados donde
vivió mucha gente durante años a la
espera de que la situación en el
salvador mejorará y muchos de ellos
vinieron a canadá y fueron el el
gobierno canadiense
tuvo una política distinta a la de otros
gobiernos como el gobierno de los eeuu
en ese entonces y canadá si recibió a
inmigrantes y refugiados hondureños que
como pasan en canadá por la
institucionalidad que tenemos
encontraron acá un camino a la
ciudadanía y hoy en día los canadienses
de origen salvadoreños son grandes
partícipes de la vida pública en canadá
y contribuyentes a la economía en canadá
porque canadá hace 40 años comenzó a
recibirlos y acogerlos no pero si hay
una conexión directa entre estas
masacres porque tuvo una incidencia no
solo en el movimiento migratorio en los
desplazados de ese entonces final lo que
se sigue viviendo hoy en día en
centroamérica aún no se ha recuperado d
la guerra que padecen las consecuencias
y lo que nosotros vemos hoy en términos
de movimientos migratorios tiene que ver
con con la consecuencia las
consecuencias de esa guerra tan terrible
justamente que de juana andrés la semana
pasada creo que fue se cumplieron 40
años de esta masacre
si fue la cada año la comunidad de
sobrevivientes va al lugar de las aradas
donde ocurrió la masacre versión pool es
una caminata de 23 obras desde los
centros poblados más cercanos y la gente
lo hace como un modo de rendir tributo a
los que allí murieron este se hacen
actos se hacen representaciones
teatrales música y una misa en memoria
de los que murieron este año no se pudo
hacer por post por la pandemia por por
las medidas de distancia social que
están en el lugar que están vigentes en
el salvador pero la gente lo que hizo
fue celebrar desde sus casas conmemorar
desde sus casas este hubo una
transmisión de una misa por las radios
locales
se acabaron y se reprodujeron
testimonios de los sobrevivientes con la
idea de que esto no se olvide también
los los sobrevivientes se han organizado
para construir un memorial en el lugar
un parque memorial no es un monumento de
cemento de concreto como suele uno
pensar cuando escucha la palabra
memorial en este caso es un memorial que
va a estar hecho es simplemente un boom
como es muy simple es un techo en medio
de unos árboles típicos del salvador que
se llaman los árboles de fuego que
florecen en el mes de mayo y que
producen una flor roja entonces este
parque memorial es un parque formado por
por árboles de fuego que van a florecer
cada año en el mes de mayo en homenaje a
las víctimas de la masacre del son pool
la comunidad está muy comprometida con
la idea de que lo que allí ocurrió no se
olvide de que se sepa de que las nuevas
generaciones conozcan lo que allí
ocurrió
y también están buscando justicia a uno
y los culpables no han sido castigados
las comunidades en chalatenango aún
tienen ese anhelo de que se haga
justicia y de que haya una reparación
por por lo que allí pasó por lo que
ocurrió y ya para terminar juan andrés
en qué fase del documental estás en este
momento
el documental en el que estoy trabajando
el proyecto está apoyado por el canal
cancel for the arts y por el london arts
camps en el consejo de las artes de
canadá y el consejo de las artes de
london ontario es la ciudad donde yo
vivo
es un proyecto donde estamos se llaman
las masacres de chalatenango y estamos
recopilando historias no solo de la
masacre del psuv pool sino de otras
masacres que tuvieron lugar a principios
de la década de los 80 el proyecto está
bastante avanzado y vamos ahora a viajar
en mayo y no y no se pudo
lamentablemente este pero pero bueno
cuando se pueda
es volver y mientras tanto estamos
trabajando en la edición es un proyecto
a largo plazo donde
la idea es no solamente registrar las
historias de estas personas sino también
registrar los lugares donde estas
masacres ocurrieron y es interesante
porque
en medio del campo en medio de las
montañas y los mismos lugares donde
ocurrieron estos hechos tan terribles
son lugares hermosos donde los
salvadoreños aún hoy hacen vidas son los
lugares donde a los que ellos sienten
que pertenece y ahorita están muy
comprometidos por ejemplo en la
preservación ambiental de la región
es una consecuencia interesante de lo
que esta gente vivió ellos tuvieron que
organizarse para sobrevivir y esas
mismas capacidades de organización que
desarrollaron en la lucha por la
supervivencia ahora las ponen en
práctica para trabajar por sus
comunidades para que sus comunidades no
entren en las pandillas o la violencia
que es característica de ciudades
grandes en el salvador
y también están muy comprometidos en la
lucha por la preservación del derecho al
agua por ejemplo o en la lucha anti
minería para que no se establezcan
compañías mineras
en la región este bueno y luchan
constantemente por por por bueno proveer
donde una mejor educación
a sus hijos este no es lo que un poco
queremos hacer todos en todas partes
y nada para mí ha sido una gran
experiencia trabajar con ellos y espero
poder retomar el trabajo pronto
hola andrés bello muchísimas gracias por
esta entrevista a radio canadá
internacional muchas gracias a ustedes
puede ser interés en este trabajo
[Música]